[Musik]
halo hat es willkommen sallys welt heute
geht s richtig leckeren schoko brötchen
wie vom bäcker samira und ella die
lieben diese brötchen und ich zeige euch
heute wie man sich selbst macht dafür
braucht ihr wirklich nur wenige zutaten
und ich mache einen hefeteig gemischt
mit einem backpulver teig und zeigt euch
wie sie machen könnt ohne dass sie zu
lange aufgehen müssen das heißt wir
können den teig gleich direkt
weiterverarbeiten fitten hefeteig
brauchen wir einen halben würfel hefe 80
gramm zucker 30 grad warmes wasser 2
eigelbe etwas vanille extrakt 220 gramm
warme milch 500 gramm
da habe ich einen 550 mm 1 teelöffel
salz ein päckchen backpulver 80 g weiche
butter und 100 gramm schokolade jetzt
hier zuerst mal den zucker die hefe die
zutaten kann man hier direkt in die
rührschüssel es auch so eine art
türkischer zeigt dass man mit hefe und
backpulver arbeitet macht man oft bei
diesem kleinen brötchen beim abschlag
zum beispiel auch ganz gerne hier kommt
jetzt etwas zucker rein das wasser
die zutaten für röhrig jetzt kurz und
hier gebe ich jetzt auch schon mal etwa
zwei esslöffel mehl dazu und dann
entsteht vielleicht wie so eine art
vortrag den lasse ich jetzt 15 bis 20
minuten auf gehen und dann kann ich
später aber den teig direkt
weiterverarbeiten
jetzt denke ich den teig erst mal ab und
lassen an dem warmen ort aufgeben ich
kann das jetzt hier in der
küchenmaschine machen mache hier etwa 34
grad
ihr könnt aber auch ganz gerne einen
vorgewärmten backofen nehmen oder
einfach kurz raumtemperatur in der nähe
von der heizung zum beispiel
[Musik]
derzeit ist es wunderbar aufgegangen und
jetzt kann man im prinzip einfach nur
noch die restlichen zutaten dazu
[Musik]
auch das backpulver der restliche zucker
kommt dazu
die eigelbe und ich nehme immer ganz
gerne nur eigelb im hefeteig war dann
noch lockerer wird und nicht trocknet
aber ich könnte auch statt zwei gelben
einfach nur ein einnehmen das geht auch
etwas relaxter und jetzt hier noch die
weiche butter dazugeben die sieht
übrigens so komisch aus weil ich
vergessen hatte butter auszulegen und
dann habe ich es einfach gerieben und
stadtspitze ganz schnell zimmer war die
schott drops noch nicht dazu geben jetzt
erst mal einen schönen geschmeidigen
teig kneten schlachten noch immer ganz
gerne 56 minuten 78 kneten
aber auch per hand kneten ich hab die
menschen vergessen
ich denke mir gerade was stimmt hier
nicht mitspielt
[Musik]
ich liebe diesen hefeteig es so schön
geschmeidig klebt nicht sehr schön
jetzt habe ich hier noch die schoko jobs
die knete ich jetzt noch kurz so ein
die sind weg fest das ist jetzt auch
ganz wichtig hat man später eine schöne
knackige schokolade mit drin
jetzt gar nicht zu sehr kneten damit die
schokoladenstückchen nicht in der hand
schmelzen jetzt vor mich hier raus 12
brötchen
das heißt es legitim einen teig ballen
hin drück mit diesem torten einteiler
ein pc mit der teig karte diese zwölf
stückchen auseinander schneiden
[Musik]
guck mal bei mir war das jetzt ein
bisschen zu warm
daher schmelzen jetzt leider die
schokostückchen etwas aber das ist nicht
schlimm ich form setzt trotzdem zu einer
kugel und wer dann einfach noch ein paar
stücke schokostückchen separaten noch
mal drauf stecken und jetzt wirklich mit
schönen viel abstand aufs blech setzen
die gehen ja noch mal auf
so sehen sie jetzt wirklich super aus
ihr könnt jetzt gerne nochmal abdecken
und für eine halbe stunde aufgehen
lassen nicht im warmen ofen damit die
schokolade jetzt erstmal noch nicht
schmilzt und dann mit ei bestreichen ich
habe jetzt hier ein ei mit einem
esslöffel milch verrührt ich mache es
jetzt allerdings so 1 denke ich ab und
bestreicht dann wirklich erst kurz vor
dem backen
denn das sorgt ja auch dafür also wie so
eine kleine haut und wenn man es zu früh
bestreicht dann trocknet das ei da drauf
und dann platzen die auf und jetzt
bestreicht aber dieses eine blech schon
mal denn dieses schiebe ich jetzt direkt
in den kalten backofen und macht dann
den ofen an und die aufwärmzeit des
ofens nutzt praktisch als aufgezeigt
also kann ich da ein bisschen zeit
sparen ihr könnt sie gerne auch auf ein
blech setzen zwölf stück aber ich will
nicht dass er sich berühren ja die soll
sich aus der ferne liebhaben
ich lebe jetzt hier nach dem streichen
einfach noch ein paar schoko drops auf
das hat jetzt nur optische gründe denn
ich möchte das auf der oberfläche auch
welche sind und es hat echt ein reiner
zufall ob gerade an dieser stelle des
teiges welche auf der oberfläche sind
und dann kommt wie gesagt das erste
blech jetzt direkt rein
das zweite denke ich mit einem tuch ab
und dann kann ich jetzt beide backen
nach dem backen werden sie denn direkt
noch mit flüssiger butter bestrichen und
dann verlieren wir sie
ich freue mich ich lebe schoko brötchen
mit kalter butter und marmelade feind
passiert ohne stückchen habt ihr jetzt
alles schon so vorteil ich ganz gleich
wo wir ja aber auch wenn jetzt nach
bagdad war schon mal eben schon
es tut mir leid aber die sind halt echt
lecker holt die zutaten wasser einfach
mal
[Musik]
meine show kaputt sind jetzt fertig und
können probiert werden
diese sind ein bisschen zu dunkel
geworden als eine minute früher hätte
ich es herausnehmen sollen aber sie sind
glaube ich mit dabei wir probieren jetzt
jetzt kommt ein kuschelbär zum probieren
oh mein gott diese von novartis liga
schießt er hätte also der papierkorb ist
und die fragen von bestimmt sind
schwarz-rot faktisch opfern vom bäcker
das blieb so echt er ohne alles oder
auch so mit butter und marmelade oder
alles echt ok du schon alles ich
probiere mit monat also auch so dass man
schon ganz nah zu sehen geben aber das
ist ja mal sehen wollte ist nicht schön
reich ich mag es ja auch ohne alles aber
was ist denn jetzt
ich habe jetzt leider nur hin wenn man
mal ab aber das geht auch hauptsache
fein passiert und ein bisschen mehr so
hoch bleiben ist das selbe problem ich
habe noch extra obendrauf
ihr müsst ihr echt ausprobieren
sie könnte auch ganz einfach mit dem
game machen total gerne mit dem er dann
nehme ich das 630 und es ändert nichts
an der konsistenz also wirklich super
folgte dem hatte den anderen noch was ab
oder sie verpacken
wir waren erst für später auf also
probiert das rezept echt mal gerne aus
ist echt super lecker und dann postet
die fotos und markiert uns damit wir
euch sehen und die fotos sehen
ich bin schon gespannt auf eure
ergebnisse also bis zum nächsten mal
und diese extra guthaben ende ich hab
sie nach dem backen weißt du einmal mit
butter bestrichen
das sagt einmal für den glanz und auch
dafür dass er wirklich fluffig soft und
weich bleiben im rat ein jogger brötchen
oder gleichstrom
frühstück ist das frühstück heute wenn
süßes isst immer mehr geld wenn es das
herz das ich komm ich hatte mir
eigentlich jemanden auf seinem
hessischen kollegen gesprochen
bester war dein foto waren es ist das
volk wohl wette gewesen
mein gott ich finde den koloss ich bin
denn pullover cool
[Musik]